here's what would happen if you traveled
to the hell planet
K2 141b is one of the most extreme lava
planets ever discovered since it's so
close to its star the unrelenting light
and heat creates temperatures of up to 3
000 degrees Celsius but the night side
of K2 141b can get as cold as minus 200
degrees Celsius and since the hell
Planet also rains rocks there won't be
any way for you to land your spacecraft
the heat on the hot side of the planet
is so extreme that it can evaporate
magma that's why the atmosphere is toxic
supersonic winds carry this mineral
Vapor over to the planet's cold side
where it rains down as quartz Pebbles
and falls into a magma ocean also it's
about seven and a half million years to
travel to K2 141b so is it really worth
it because